dans ce collège triellois c'est bientôt
la fin des travaux
l'établissement se voit notamment dotés
de sanitaires pour les élèves de 6e et
une d'une cage d'ascenseur
un chantier à 2 millions d'euros c'est
des rénovations qui sont programmés
depuis plusieurs années ce collège avait
besoin d'un bon coup de neuf et aussi de
travaux qu'ils vont permettre à tous les
élèves de venir
il est l'un des 56 établissements a
bénéficié de travaux durant l'été à
travers le département 70 chantiers sont
en cours ou vont débuter comme les
collèges gagarine et le village attrape
ou celui des saules à guyancourt
les travaux c'est simplement d'aller
changer complètement un bloc sanitaire
de les refaire des peintures dans les
salles de classe dale est équipé d'une
manière numérique et plus efficace
encore que ceux qui étaient dans tel ou
tel collège où des travaux plus lourds
est des travaux d'un budget de 23
millions d'euros pour cet été 2010 9 le
département prévoit la construction
prochaine de nouveaux collèges les
travaux à mantes-la-jolie débuteront en
septembre de cette année à
vélizy-villacoublay verneuil-sur-seine
et guyancourt la livraison est prévue
pour 2023